I stutter a lot I couldn't speak to  someone I clearly didn't I everything is  just intimidating to me I used to be a  totally different person before I got  into the program look at me now I'm the  group commander number one I'm in charge  teller Eric I really want to be a  warrior inside the military and I have  to do a lot of things to get there and  that's what I love about it because it  pushed me to starting just like artists  II pushed me I'm a very determined  person I won't stop until I hear what I  want so practice practice practice and  practice for sciencv if I have to study  more about and stay off I will do it to  get there you know there's a reward at  the end but I'm not working for the  rewards and I'm working for something  big  I'm gonna keep going because this is  what I want to do this is my goal and I  want to accomplish it  [Music]